so some are accusing trump lawyer  michael van der veen of  stealing coasters from the senate floor  let's watch  yeah he seems to be taking some coasters  though we don't actually see him walk  away with the coasters  yeah i mean arguably he's taking some  coasters but those coasters are there  to be taken they're disposable and come  on if you're a lawyer on the senate  floor arguing your case in front of the  country  i think you deserve some souvenirs to  take home some  senate embroidered coasters i think  that's okay the trump lawyers did a lot  that deserves criticism  but taking a handful of coasters home as  souvenirs probably not one of them but  of course i would say that i'm a lawyer  and speaking of which subscribe or i'll  see you  in court